come on
you know sometimes there's a toxic
masculinity like you just seen five
dudes being mad supportive the weakest
one they don't care they're all very
short and a lot of Praise they show
their love they're pushing each other to
do more and do better because they talk
about Jim bro Jim bro mentality but in
my experience the ones who are most
accepting of fat people of skinny people
of people who are trying to better their
lives in a real genuine way where they
show effort they show interest they're
consistently being supportive and my
experience is the only space that I've
ever seen be that supportive have been
Jim bro uh spaces we brought together
five men and had them rank each other
based on their perceived strength then
we put them to the test to reveal their
actual strength this is a ranking
as cliche and corny it is to say and I
hate seeing it working out as a
lifestyle I schedule my workouts and
it's kind of like oh like Isaac you want
to do this I'm like okay I gotta make
sure like it's not interfering with my
workout time
100 of Lifestyle
it's yeah it is the minute you just I
gotta wake up in the morning to work or
you put some it's a lifestyle yeah
definitely yeah I agree with that it's
something like every day that you look
forward to doing I would say it's
between working out and gaming the guy
on the far left looks very military
lifting heavy I started actually weight
lifting when I was in high school I had
the reputation of being the guy that was
bigger just kind of kept that going yeah
I was also an eighth grade it was during
the summer and I was at a pool party
with all my friends we were just like
jumping up down the pool like just
having a great time and then one of the
girls that had a crush on was like Hey
Edward carry me throw me into the pool I
was like all right I got this girl
just go into the pool about to go and
she's like oh my God Edward stop stop
I'm just like oh what happened and she's
like you're shaking so much like I don't
feel comfortable in your arms right now
oh man after that I just went home
yep and be those kinds of moments that
you remember forever bro they just be
changing you
those little moments where they make a
comment I remember one time I was in PE
class okay I was like maybe I had to
have been 15. yeah I mean I was fresh
off the boat from Ethiopia you know
maybe a buck 40 soaking wet okay and you
know I'm over there just chilling in P
class everybody got these shorts we're
all doing physical Ed and this girl
about it she said hey you remember today
hey it's okay you know you know it went
hey you know it hit hey hey hey she's
like yo and she just sat on my lap and I
was like hey you know I mean instant
boner I'm not gonna say nothing I'm
playing it cool and she talking to me
bro it took like done but 10 seconds for
my leg to be like
it's like are you okay why you think are
you nervous I'm like nah I wasn't
nervous
Under Pressure she just weighed a little
bit more than I expected
what happens you're nervous no fat [__]
you just a little Hefty she was a fan I
was just mad skinny and I was what it
was
Hey listen there's moments in my life
why is a man as an older man I can
appreciate those moments now
and I'm not even mad at them when I'm
like I ain't strong enough for this you
know when a six foot tall Amazonian
woman says oh I like to be put up and
I'm like word and I just move on from
that like I didn't hear it I know what
it is she's like I like to get picked up
like okay I'll go get my car yay
you into what do you like when you went
with a guy you know like when y'all
making love and she's like I like to get
picked up and I was like we're moving on
because that's never gonna happen with
me or we're gonna have love on a
forklift good [__] that's not happening
it it cannot be me I'm sorry
um when I was pretty young
um I got very interviewed what's your
story I'm short
I got very into video games and I I
started playing like Star Wars and Lara
Croft what really got me into it was I
was actually buried ever since I was in
elementary because I was always like a
bigger taller kid and all my friends
were like oh dude Isaac you're so big
like I bet like I bet you're so strong
and then they would actually end up
physically hurting me like I didn't know
what to do and so as I got older like in
middle school that's when I was like
okay I gotta change something and so I
started lifting then when I squat bench
deadlift as heavy as possible that's
when I feel really empowered no I'm so
sorry about that that happened to you
because no one should be shamed for how
they look when you tell them short King
nobody
and uplifting so it's good
just to put it out there I think I'm
just gonna rank myself as the least
strongest oh my God Edward stop you're
shaking so much I will go that way too I
don't want to be here
so for me I think it's between you two I
feel like you you just have a lot of
knowledge and you know a lot and your
motivation I just feel like you're
you're out there but then you just like
look at your clock
we also got that [__] suction cup
marks and you learn a tank top that
anybody know an accident you have to let
him know [__] you know how much I'd be
lift I gotta take care of this body body
is that what they say I don't know come
on I feel like that's your department
come on that's not like in your
department though that sounds like some
some Caribbean you know
foreign
that's no Caribbean right there I feel
like I walked by a dancehall place and
heard that one time no you already Yes
okay but not body and body and Yardie no
no we're not body yachty yeah
and Caribbean that's really what you got
I'm pretty sure
no you haven't I have look at you guys
have the size of my my thighs I mean
these are genetics
looks aren't everything but you look
strong and it's like it can be deceiving
that's why I feel like we if we have
like a clear definition on what we are
defining strength as we're also gonna
test ourselves with that so I think we
should go based off around ourselves
with that all right so who do we think
is going to deadlift the most how do you
feel being there uh I feel like we
should switch I actually feel like the
raw power and the rush strength that you
have without the technique if we just
compare that I feel like either of you
two are stronger than me I'm very unsure
of that I don't agree to be honest but
for him in the middle I don't I don't
agree I like how Brandon's and last
because he put himself there and no one
no no yeah you run less it's not even a
bad thing please tell me about that one
okay I think Isaac's just stay number
one though and then and then I think
these two should switch I agree with
that can I actually ask what do you do
for a living military military got it
again the far left looks very military
I'm just telling he did it again I'm
telling y'all he
a bar and you've been count based off
posture the way they look you're just
like I could tell this dude where's his
combats on a regular basis he stands
like it yeah I just I look at this guy
the lineup and everything is very good
army the minute you said it I was like
you're so right you are so right about
that [__] it was really creepy the the
mustache the length of the eyes you know
what else is you know this it's also the
way they dress when they're in civilian
civilian clothes military guys when
they're in civilian clothes they wear
like well fitted t-shirts and the
ugliest shorts something about that like
it says there's like zero fashion sense
some physical training yeah it's really
that they all they all get dressed like
they bought their clothes at the canteen
uh I'm a mail carrier male male carrier
yeah oh that's pretty good too I don't
know you guys walk a lot I feel like
well I feel like mail carriers can be
strong because there's still a lot of
lifting involved yeah with packages
that's a lot but military army or uh
army marines you wouldn't guess it okay
space got it boy you so jacked as hell
man yo you gotta find aliens yeah I
think yeah
and the thing is that the military
oftentimes often times instantly they're
functional
they're strong but functioning strong
pumps too much your heart pumps too much
like I've seen some jack dude but it's
not most of the people in the military I
I feel like they're very much
correct me on that one if I'm wrong I
feel like most of them they're strong
but very functioning strong you're not
going to see like the biggest [__]
legs necessarily nah that's not true
what do you mean no there's there's
disgustingly yoke people in the military
is that a majority uh I would tell you
the amount of steroids I've seen in the
military never lifting never mind man
definitely I disagree heavily never mind
yeah I used to go to the gym that
[__] were really packing them
absolutely yeah you'll see a lot of big
dudes
you guys
[Applause]
[Music]
that was a good form too there ain't
nothing worse than what I watch at
deadlifts in somebody's backs look like
it about to be broken forever there's a
side you know what they say snap City
that's just so fast there's some people
but they don't let I be dying in socks
I'm like bro
you deserve to have kids someday why are
you doing this to us you saw the dude
that that died recently because he was
squatting he was squatting 405 and it
was just one person behind them spotting
him or bar spotting him not two people
in the side his back snapped okay I
don't even want to hear about that yeah
yeah so all right I just want to add
like Italian okay
I've only done this once before hey
you're about to do this all the time
take your time
35.
[Applause]
come on
you can do it I don't want to push you
too much five five okay okay y'all did
this to me
all right boys
[Applause]
don't you want to take a second to pause
this just to like send you know they're
all having their little bro moment but
this is what a lot of male spaces look
like you know sometimes it's like a
toxic masculine like you just seen five
dudes being mad supportive the weakest
one they don't care they're all very
short and a lot of Praise they show in
love they're pushing each other to do
more and do better so I don't know
sometimes this is what I see when I see
a lot of male spaces no that's toxic
mentality but my experience the ones who
are most accepting of fat people of
skinny people of people who are trying
to better their lives in a real genuine
way where they show effort they show
interest they're consistently being
supportive and my experience is the only
space that I've ever seen be that
supportive have been Jim bro uh spaces
yes easy work easy work
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the kind of [__] that
when like he doesn't look ripped when
he's wearing clothes I've seen yo
there's so many guys like that where
they wear they don't look like nothing's
going on if they were if they were cars
they would be sleepers you understand
you just do okay so I car nice colors
okay rims or and then when they take
they see it's it's Rip City or maybe
he's just asleep at the wheel
they look like sleepers no I think he's
just sleeping but we'll find out he he
didn't want to do the pr he didn't want
to do he wanted no not only is this
gonna be my PR I'm gonna add 10. I'm
like okay I made it don't [__] it up
let's go
his back is around us [__] though
ah it's gonna hurt in two days yeah
cause the hurt happens two days after
not right after two days after that back
was rounder than a [__] but
maybe he's going to be able to do it but
that looks quiet yeah yeah yeah bro
oh
[Applause]
you have a thick back yep
record
this guy's got raw powers
sorry sorry this sorry sorry but just
gives me anxiety what if it just it's
because I care let's just say I don't
want to see nobody get hurt have you
ever seen someone pass out after a lift
see that shit's scary because you kind
of see there they that God and then you
see the the soul leave the body is is
not fun
[Applause]
475 475 easy work I know it's no that
was not easy work it didn't look easy at
all hey but you could be so important
let's be honest that spine is screaming
it's a lot of weight and he about to
make it look easy yeah I'm telling you
he's like carrying in weight all of us
[Applause]
disrespect this Wing real quick
[Music]
we got it let's go let's go let's go
come on
we're locking in baby
[Music]
of the guys who did the highest weight
that was the cleanest one yes yeah but
he did a sumo right it's a bit different
right but you
choose the technique that you can to
lift the weight that you can so he did a
Sumo fine so consider deadlift it is but
it's not the same because like the
reason why I'm saying is if they're
doing a ranking of strength and one
person's doing a Sumo at a higher weight
it's not the same as someone doing a
regular technique there a regular deck
that's what you're saying it's still
impressive I'm not trying to shut up
yeah I'm just saying they're doing the
ranking it doesn't make sense they
should all do the same technique I
understand yeah Fair
this is fun experience 525 I'm surprised
it moved up a lot faster than I thought
because I didn't work out this whole
week but the fact that she didn't work
out this this whole week means that
you're arrested yeah this helps sure
yeah no now what's that's what I
not that you see other people and
sometimes you judge them just because
how big they are like I'm big but I
cannot do it like weight as they do but
it's just a misconception that you think
muscle big muscles are better but it's
not about that it's about your passion
and how much time do you invest on it
stand like this
from here
and then the thing is that stroll at
your knees Buckle that's good
what are your thoughts on the video uh
my thoughts is
um deadlifts have the worst
the worst for
return on investments
you're not a fan
it's just not the best for return of
investment in what like you have more a
high rates of uh injuring yourself and
yeah I could do 425 but then and do one
rep but then the return on that I rather
have a higher
rep than a higher weight yeah but I
think this is a PR thing for that yeah
it's not a workout it's just an
achievement it is I just say in general
yeah yeah not everyone's going to the
gym every day doing one rep I think most
people if they're doing a workout
routine they probably have higher volume
and but they'll do the one rep to see
the strength of the progression and it's
also there's a difference like strength
is so arbitrary like it depends yeah you
could lift the most but I could lift the
longest who's really stronger I don't
know you know you can lift one time and
after that you're gonna be dead but
there's some people like a lift and lift
and lift and lift and power through so
I don't know what's going to be the
strongest you know I mean it's like it's
like when I was doing track oh yeah
you're the fastest because you want yeah
I run fast on a hundred meters but I
cannot keep that up for two kilometers
like I can't keep that up for like a
mile or or or or or Marathon or whatever
so really who's fastest you know what I
mean I could I could be dead last in a
long distance but really so
see a little bit of both and then
there's there's there's being uh there's
people that are big and strong and you
look at the form and some people are
just really there's being strong but
it's not it doesn't serve you any
purpose you have big muscles you have
big defined muscles and everything and
stuff and you are strong and you're able
to deadlift you're able to push you're
both the best press but you cannot move
around and you get really tired a lot
you know some of the people that are
just a little bit more normal and are
able to do all those things so strengths
is very
I'm not gonna base myself and just
deadlift it's then again it's a video so
yeah
yeah I think for Me overall I enjoyed it
I think it was cool watching the dynamic
and I think it's cool to see one of
these kinds of videos not get towards
some kind of like competitive Hot Potato
situation or really awkward or cringy
which is very supportive and cool and um
yeah I think that's just been my
experience with most gym culture so it
was cool seeing you reflected in this
video as well got a question what's the
problem with the like where what's the
problem with the Jim bro mentality and
Jim Rowan people look like they I think
they take them around they're just like
you'll see some with a lot of muscles
and then they'll think that person's
really vain or they'll see someone who
works out a lot that really can you know
focus on their body and their physique
and then it seem like they're dumb just
interested in women probably very
arrogant or whatever and so that that
stereotype perpetuates itself but I
don't know I just I've been a lot of
gyms where there's military civilian
life and I just never really saw that
kind of attitude perpetually throughout
most of the gym I was actually very
surprised because like I remember when I
first started lifting like the guys
who've been there for a long time doing
some of the crazy exercises were just
mad cool very humble
um and so that's really the first ones
that want to help you yes if you do
something or if you want to ask for any
questions or whatever they're very open
um and so they've been hurt and they
don't want to have that to happen to you
so but maybe your experience in the gym
is very very different than me uh but
I've seen that stereotype perpetuates I
don't I don't believe it's true
um maybe on Instagram I guess but real
life is just not my reality so I don't
think that Instagram is necessarily real
life for anything but sure did you at
some point you started to train a lot
after the leggings since and when what
you stopped at some point
no no so in the military I was like
really big so I remember just you know I
took a lot of time with physique and
working out and bodybuilding all that
stuff right so I was spending a lot of
time in the gym
and then after the military I was just
doing more dance related stuff and doing
other things and so I just wasn't doing
it as often
um so yeah of me I just still I have my
kettlebells at home and then I have my
pull-up stuff and my dip and I just use
that at home I prefer doing body stuff
I'm not a I'm not a gym person I don't
get that much gratification from going
to the gym right but I liked the
atmosphere when I was there hmm so
that's my experience with it but I've
always respected I think it's cool
I just prefer biking nowadays for going
out dancing or doing well it's practical
on top of that so yeah this is more
enjoyable for me it's just more
functional so this is what I do it for
functional on the word I was looking for
cool
um
what gym you at we want to go find you
well what do I train at yeah I I fight
what's your experience with working off
I well I was I was working out when I
went Outfield power stuff just burst of
power really quickly uh get me out of
trouble I don't think I would be like a
Troublesome kid but I really liked it
just because it gave me something to do
and and as a kid that was Billy like I
was excelling there so it was giving me
confidence and at least I was good at
that stuff you know I was not really
good at school I was not really good
with people so at least that there I was
able to perform right
um then after that
was really more uh I went into fighting
right capoeira I had a couple with a
couple of a couple of years if you don't
know what capoeira is a Brazilian
martial art
and I did a couple of other things and
now I'm more into more Thai and I still
go to the gym like uh I went I went back
to the gym recently but yeah
the fight sometimes going to the gym and
even fighting sometimes it's not even a
fight against someone else or a
competition is really you having to
motivate or motivate yourself to get up
and go trains even when you don't feel
like it or just surpassing yourself and
your own goal so that's always a like a
nice thing to have in a mentality so the
gym thing that I like people talking
about bad about people that go to the
gym and stuff like that or people that
just train them like yeah it's not
necessarily that it's
it's a weird thing because I go to the
gym and like I see all these ladies and
the mood really changed like right now
people are really
like guys they're in the mood and the
gym is weird because you had guys always
walking up to you and trying to help you
and stuff like that my gym there's a lot
more women than I've ever seen in the
gym ever right and we
mine our [__] business if you get
hurt you get hurt
yeah yes yes yes yes yes I'm
disappointed yes a hundred percent my
guy someone's gonna walk yeah and
someone's gonna walk with like are you
done with that are you done with that
huh yeah I'm done with it you can use it
that's a general feeling I can tell you
that much
like that without helping them
so what
yeah
but I felt that the mood really changed
and really quickly a lot less people are
talking and I think it's a good thing
you know he came here to talk or you
gave me the train not to talk so carry